guys tell me a little bit about working
together on anti-viral I had a great
time yeah my gut to bleed from my mouth
and these be sick and spend time with
Brandon so it was great I had the same
experience lots of blood out of my mouth
and I had a wonderful time you've worked
with no say any Brandon but also his dad
happened you on two films in fact
Cosmopolis and Dangerous Method tell me
a little bit about how they compares
directors this is I I compared them
often while I was working i sat there I
had I took the liberty of drafting up a
comparative sheet before I would go to
set every day and then I just kind of
had like a checkbox system where I would
just check whether or not Brandon was up
to the same measure as his father and
then I and then I and then I presented
the fact sheet to him at the end so he
could improve really process the results
were that scientifically I'm not as good
as my father must do better
statistically he's on his way Brandon
tell me a little bit about that whole
kind of gore eNOS you have in the film
because it really is quite out there
isn't it in terms of celebrity obsession
do you think we could get that far the
gore eNOS level if we try you all you
have to do is cut yourself open then
you're like so you've got the blood in
you already it's really easy it tells
the celebrity obsession as well just it
will ever reach the stage where people
are eating celebrity self states yes
definitely
I'm trying to get there as soon as
possible he's actually put forth the
idea so really someone just needs to
execute no this was really a business
proposal and Sarah what's it like for
you as well you're kind of in that
service I aren't you how do you feel
about it as an actress as well as being
in the film but kind of set apart from
it what do you think about that
celebrity culture no I really hope that
no one would eat me in any form so yeah
I feel I feel very far removed from it
though so other than right now where I
feel like
what's next see you know now you've got
a couple of films coming out haven't you
this an enemy in ballast well yeah I'm
actually in London right now shooting
Bell and that's been really great I just
got back from the Isle of Man which was
an island with men on it and no and I'm
really happy to be shooting here because
it's a beautiful city did you enjoy
about a particular I like chips chips
are great it's better than french fries
yes we call them french fries but I was
swiftly corrected so I like chips now in
front of what you enjoying about being
here in London this this is a great just
talking to you and what would you like
to be doing next hopefully make another
film I'm trying to write something yeah
horror genre or what would it be like
you think maybe I haven't quite figured
it out yet
probably a little something like that
great to speak to both you guys a good
luck with antiviral thank you
you